[Music]
for me to kind of balance it all I came
up with this notion of what I call the
12-hour rule it's very easy to tell
someone to do something right but
telling them how is a different story
love yourself more okay great well I've
always been told I was crap so how do I
get to that headspace oh make time for
yourself prioritize your well-being
yeah well I'm spread so thin you could
see through me how so the how for me was
this 12 hour rule I said all right I'm
gonna focus on sleep I'm gonna get seven
to eight hours of sleep at night that's
gonna leave me with about a hundred and
twelve waking hours in my week if I do
fifty hours on work forty hours
he's the normal work week I'm gonna add
ten if I do fifty hours on running my
household and if you're lucky enough to
not be a single parent and you have a
significant other you get to borrow some
of their fifty hours to run household
right so this is our worst-case scenario
and this is where you're taking the dog
to the vet and you're taking the car to
get the tires rotated and you're
shuttling the kids back and forth
between soccer and gymnastics how do I
know this because I do all of that stuff
in the 50 hours I dedicate to running my
friggin household I'm left with about 12
hours of me time and I schedule that 12
hours each and every week like it is the
Word of God and what I do with it is as
follows I take four half hours for
exercise even if I don't have the drive
time to and from the gym and it's
happening in my living room with
something I'm streaming to my TV from an
app so be it
next I might see friends for brunch or a
dinner that could be a couple of hours
I'm at about four hours now I've got a
doctor's appointment a haircut a dentist
appointment any routine maintenance on
my hygiene and my health I'm fitting
into another two hours of that week I'm
somewhere now at what six to eight hours
I've got a date night I'm at maybe 10
hours and it doesn't mean I don't see my
significant other at home it's like a
special time for us to go out during the
week and I got a couple hours left over
for a hobby
it could be riding my horse it could be
relaxing with a book it could be
whatever you love I don't care if it's
needlepoint if it makes you happy who
cares over the course of the month that
4 hours of fitness is enough to keep
body healthy that weekly routine
maintenance appointment is enough to
make sure all the health checks and
balances are checking out for better
right you're maintaining your good
relationships with friends and
significant others and you get just
enough time to chill out it's not
perfect not the perfect parent I'm not
the perfect business woman about the
perfect anything but it's enough to keep
the wheels on this bus and to maintain a
level of happiness which means meaning
and purpose to tolerate the days where
things go wrong and I screw up it's
worth it
[Music]